[Musique]
Et maintenant, retrouvons une nouvelle
histoire de Papi Grenier.
Papi, coucou papi papi. Papi. Non, les
enfants, venez par ici.
Ah, dégueulasse. Papi, papi, tu nous
racontes une histoire ? Ah, une histoire
? Est-ce que je vous ai raconté
l'histoire de votre 4e petit frère ?
Parce que vous êtes quatre à la base
hein. Et puis un jour la mafia russe est
venue et elle a enlevé pour ses organes.
Bah alors, est-ce que je vous ai raconté
la fois où j'étais un scientifique mué
célèbre ? C'était en 1998 et à cette
époque la version porno BDSM des minium
n'était pas encore
sortie. Tout a commencé par une journée
classique. Je travaillais au complexe
Black Messa, centre de recherche qui
menait des études sur la téléportation.
Mais c'était bizarre, j'allais au boulot
et j'étais tout seul dans la rame du
tram. Bonjour monsieur Freeman. Vous
êtes en retard, on dirait. Ah oui, c'est
pour ça qu'il y avait personne. Ce truc
14h. Oh là là, quel branleur. Alors,
c'était un institut ultra moderne. On
avait des grosses caisses en bois, des
murs rouillés et des fuites de liquides
vert fluoréchant. Qu'est-ce qui aurait
pu mal se passer hein ? Nous avions la
fine crème des scientifiques toujours
sur la brèche. Excusez-moi, Gordon, mais
je suis très occupé.
Je suis donc allé enfiler ma tenue.
Alors, elle était ultra performante.
Elle indiquait la santé, les fractures,
l'énergie de la combinaison, le rythme
cardiaque. Elle donnait l'heure, elle
faisait lecteur MP3 et d'autres menus
fonction. Munition pour fusil à pompe
calibre 12. Mais papi, tu étais pas un
scientifique ? Oui, je compte bien le
rester. Et comment je fais pour me
défendre contre les Indiens ? Hein ?
Hein ? Mais il y en a plus des Indiens.
Ouais mais c'est pas grâce à toi
Tarlouse. Du coup je m'étais dirigé vers
la salle de test. Tout se passait
parfaitement bien. On aurait vraiment
jamais pu deviner que ça allait mal
tourner. C'est sur le point de
lâcher. Mais qu'est-ce qu'il a cet
appareil ? Non mais tout va bien, ils
servent à rien ces ordis. Regardez, il y
a rien dedans.
[Musique]
C'est vrai. Et puis quand tu les
écoutais parler, tu sentais qu'il savait
ce qu'il faisait. À votre avis, qui a
fini les beigners ? Même si tous mes
collègues étaient très doués, moi aussi
j'étais super qualifié hein. On m'avait
engagé parce que j'étais le meilleur
dans mon domaine. Voilà. Mais God Fleman
papi, on comprend rien. Mais évidemment,
pourquoi vous croyez que je parlais
jamais à l'époque ? Je comprenais pas un
mot de ce qu'il disait. 30 ans j'ai
passé là-bas. Ils m'ont jamais grillé
ces gringoss. Enfin, je vais vous faire
la traduction. Je suis Gordon Freeman,
diplômé en physique théorique. J'ai un
doctorat de l'école du Massachusetts.
J'ai fait 8 ans d'études pour travailler
dans ce centre. Alors maintenant,
excusez-moi, j'ai un chariot à pousser.
8 ans d'études. Chouchou baigné. Mais
qu'est-ce qu'il fabrique ? Ne vous
inquiétez pas Gordon, tout va bien.
Continuez. C'était ça ton travail papi ?
Quoi ? Je vous emmerde, j'ai une théorie
en physique de chaussettes. Et tu as
réussi à le pousser le chariot papi ?
Non.
Mais papi, comment tu as pu arrêter un
truc aussi simple ?
Fracture importante. Injection de
morphine. Injection de morphine.
Injection de morphine.
Injection de morphine. Mais je sais pas
mon petit Jonathan. Je m'appelle
Stéphanie. Oh oui, Stéphanie c'est un
joli nom pour un lapin. Infirmière. Où
est ma morphine ? Bref, tout avait
explosé. C'était une réaction en chaîne
résonnante ou je sais pas trop quoi. En
même temps, merde, moi j'étais juste
payé pour pousser des chariots. Mes
collègues, ils étaient mal en point par
contre. Il y en a certains qui étaient
blessés. Tu es allé les aider papi ? Oh
de de bah de oui,
[Musique]
évidemment. Mais j'étais vivant, c'est
ça qui était important. J'avais trouvé
une arme surpuissante, un pied de biche.
Il suffisait de mettre un petit coup et
tu réduis n'importe quoi en bouille.
Injection de morphine. Et puis aussi des
flinges, des mitraillettes, des armes
lourdes, des grenades, des
lancer-roquettes. Comment tu savais te
servir de tout ça papi ? Oh, j'ai habité
3 mois dans le 93. Rapidement, le
gouvernement a envoyé des militaires
pour étouffer l'affaire. J'ai résolu
cette situation comme le ferait
n'importe quel homme de science.
Après, ils ont envoyé les Black Ops.
C'est des nanas en cuir moulant. super
agile. Non, vous aurez pas ma morphie.
Et plus que ça, le gouvernement avait
également envoyé un homme, le Gman.
J'arrêtais pas de le croiser partout,
tout le temps, à croire qu'il me
suivait, qu'il avait un plan diabolique
et qu'il savait tout à l'avance. Enfin
ça ou alors il était perdu, ça marche
aussi. Alors à droite et ensuite tout
droit. Non, ça va aller, vous inquiétez
pas. Ouais, ça va aller. Ah mais [ __ ]
je suis où là ? Mais il m'a dit à droite
après le tunnel. Excusez-moi. Vous
seriez où je peux trouver l'accueil ? Ah
non, mais vraiment ça ressemble pas du
tout àé. Mais le plus étonnant, ce
n'était pas les soldats ou les forces du
gouvernement ou même le GMA. Non,
c'était que la résonance avait ouvert un
passage vers un autre monde et que des
extraterrestres en étaient sortis. Vous
vous rendez compte ? Des extraterrestres
? Oh mon Dieu, c'est incroyable. Il
existe donc d'autres formes de vie dans
l'univers. Ça ouvre tellement de
perspectives. Il a donc fallu que je
m'échappe de la base tout en combattant
et je suis passé par plein d'endroits.
La boucherie, le train de la mine, le
lac de déchets bactériologique, la
rivière
radioactive. Vous inquiétez pas, j'ai
une combinaison. Faut juste y aller
doucement et respirer profondément.
Et j'étais complètement seul. Les
soldats voulaient nous tuer, les
extraterrestres voulaient nous tuer. Les
seuls alliés que je rencontrais, c'était
des gardes qui parfois me suivaient et
qui avaient un problème avec la boisson.
Je crois qu'on aura mérité bière après
tout ça. À tout à l'heure devant une
bière là. Une bonne bière bien fraîche,
ça me dirait bien.
47 fois 47 fois je lu a proposé, il est
pas venu. Tout ce que je voulais moi
c'est c'était boire un verre avec un ami
hein. C'est trop
demandé. Le ch moyen pour arrêter
l'invasion des extraterrestres était
donc d'envoyer un satellite dans
l'espace. Alors le plan était sans
faille. Attendez, qu'est-ce qu'il
m'avait dit déjà le scientifique ? Je
peux vous donner quelque chose contre la
douleur
? Cependant, malgré le lancement réussi,
le satellite n'avait pas réussi à
refermer la feuille extraterrestre. Par
contre, maintenant, j'avais une 4G qui
défonce. Du coup, j'ai décidé d'aller
vers le complexe Lambada. Mais sur le
chemin, je me suis fait capturer par des
militaires. Ils m'ont jeté dans un
compacteur à hordure, mais j'ai pu m'en
échapper facilement. Vous êtes sûr qu'on
le met dans ce compacteur à ordure avec
les caisses qui forment un petit
escalier pour sortir ? Allez-y, vous en
connaissez un autre de compacteur à
ordure là, monsieur, je sais tout. Le
complexe Lambada était un vrai
labyrinthe. C'était là où on menait les
expériences sur la
[Musique]
téléportation. Fa quand même que je
pense leur demander à quoi ça servait
tous ces machins parce que je vois pas
le rapport avec la téléportation. En
tout cas, après pas mal de voyages,
j'arrivais au réacteur central et les
scientifiques avaient tout préparé pour
m'envoyer sur Xen, la planète des
aliens. Un endroit étrange, un rempli de
gros bébés qui parlent et de monstre
couilles qui crachent des trucs blancs.
Et alors papi, comment ça c'est fini ?
Et ben je sais pas, il y a le mec à la
mette qui réapparu et qui m'a dit des
trucs. Et là, le mec qui me dit "Va à
droite." Ben moi, qu'est-ce que je fais
? J'avance et je vais à droite. Et puis
c'est vraiment mal indiqué là. Oh là là
là là. OK. Ah oui, si vous passez ce
téléporteur, je vous offre un mystérieux
emploi et tout s'arrêtera là parce qu'on
a vraiment aucune idée de comment finir
cette histoire en fait. Mais pas du
tout, vraiment aucune idée. Mais vous
inquiétez pas, dans le 2, de on va
continuer l'histoire et tout vous sera
expliqué dans le 3. Oh ben ça va, je
suis rassuré. Alors
mais papi, c'est pas une histoire ça,
c'est un jeu vidéo quoi. Elle vient d'où
mon addiction la morphine ? Alors hein ?
Papi, papi, tu nous racontes une autre
histoire ? Non, bien sûr, mais ça sera
pour la prochaine fois.